i'm ready okay
welcome everyone to the second day of
this workshop uh thanks for coming um in
the morning
and uh we're happy to have jonathan
leakes going to tell us about continuous
maximum entropy distributions
okay thanks uh cole and uh thank you to
the organizers for inviting me to give
this talk uh i had planned to be there
in person
um unfortunately some
bureaucracy sort of there were some
issues but uh in any case i'm still
going to give this talk and feel free if
you have any questions just to interrupt
me
at any point and i'll try to answer them
okay and this is uh yeah joint work with
nishith
and let's let's get started
okay so i'm going to start off with a
question here
um the question goes as follows suppose
we have some some subset of of r to the
d call it m okay and let let's let k
denote the convex hole of this m
and let this capital a be some point in
this convex hull so these three
letters we're going to use throughout
the talk for these
kind of things okay suppose we have
these things
so here's the question is there some
canonical way to express a
as a convex combination of the points in
m and
i put convex combination in quotes here
is because really what i'm looking for
is some probability distribution on m
um whose expectation is a
right of course there are many ways to
do this is there some sort of natural
one or some canonical way to do this to
choose this
okay
and if we suppose that m is a discrete
set so some let's say some finite set of
points which we'll see a picture that's
more uh relevant to that case in a
second here but if we suppose that m is
discrete
then there is sort of an answer to this
which is basically let's choose the
distribution on this discrete set which
which maximizes the shannon entropy so
we would look at all distributions with
expectation uh a
and we would choose the one that
maximizes entropy
okay and this was already kind of this
idea was was given by james uh in the
50s so so quite a long time ago okay and
so naturally these distributions that
you know if we pick such a distribution
we're going to call it a maximum entropy
distribution okay
um this is also generalizable i
generally won't really refer to this
generalization that often but i mean
one thing that you could do is somehow
uh
maximum entry distributions are related
to to the uniform distribution say on
this on this set of discrete this
discrete set of points um but if you if
you somehow had like a prior
distribution some some kind of
information you had
extra that you wanted to add in you
could also instead of maximizing entropy
you could minimize relative entropy with
respect to this prior distribution um
but
up to this detail basically um you're
still kind of maximizing entropy and so
i'm just going to be using this term
maximum entropy distributions throughout
but just know that if you have a sense
of what this callback library
divergences you can also uh
minimize relative entropy with respect
to uh some other distribution
okay anyway but in this discrete case um
there are already a lot of uh
applications which we're going to see
exactly uh i'm going to give you some
more concrete details about this or at
least some references
connections to combinatorial
inequalities discrete approximation
this very recent new
improvement to the metric traveling
salesperson algorithm approximation is
related to this
and then there are some some other
examples which we've either already seen
this week or maybe we'll see later this
week related to scaling algorithms um
orbits and also to statistical model
okay but maybe okay so maybe we have
some applications here we would this is
this is then maybe something we want to
think about the question is how do we
actually compute this right this is some
um optimization problem over a set of
of uh
probability distributions and uh maybe
this if the set m is quite large maybe
this is difficult to do so how can we do
this
okay
so now here's the a picture more
relevant to this discrete case okay so
now suppose we have this m this this set
of these black points here okay k is the
convex hole this gray area and now a is
some point in the convex hole
okay so this is our discrete situation
okay and so
this primal problem that i've written
down here is exactly the maximum entropy
optimization problem so this is exactly
what i was describing before
this quantity is the entropy of some
distribution mu
okay and i'm looking for the maximum
overall distributions
supported on m that have expectation a
so this is exactly right the optimal
new here is exactly the maximum entropy
distribution
it turns out that there is a convex dual
form to this which can be written like
this
okay and and the key
uh actually i'll say that in a second so
basically the idea then is in this
discrete case this dual program
can be uh efficiently computed you can
efficiently optimize this using the
ellipsoid method as long as basically
you can compute these sums efficiently
okay and this is these are this discrete
case there are some previous results of
the sheath and co-authors here
um but the things that that's important
to think about when you look at this
right so okay so i have this primal this
primal problem this is the maximum
entropy problem um right a priori
this entropy is some concave function so
doing convex optimization here is
is is not is not a it's not hard one one
can one can do this the problem is often
this set m is is quite large so if you
know for instance if you look at this
picture the set m
uh has maybe like a huge number of
points compared to the dimension of the
ambient space which here is just two
okay and so what this primal dual pair
allows you to do is to optimize
something
that's somehow much smaller the search
space is much smaller and that's kind of
the first observation here by going from
primal to dual you can shrink the search
space dimension quite a bit okay and so
this this can enable you to do things a
lot more efficiently than if you just
looked at this naively
okay the other thing that this gets you
is a very special form for the maximum
entropy distribution okay and
the reason why you can even solve the
dual program to get the solution for the
primal is you have some kind of strong
duality relationship right that says
that the solution to this problem is
equal to the solution to this
and what that also gives you is
somehow now this maximum entropy
distribution has to be very related to
this this optimal y and that's exactly
what this says right that says that
maximum entropy distributions
are always of this log linear form e to
some linear function
okay this is some particular
um yeah this log linear function here
okay and another comment i will make
here is that
if you kind of transform this a little
bit by maybe
exponentiating this this objective and
maybe uh exponentiating some input here
um you end up getting this polynomial
capacity problem in fact this dual is is
pretty much equivalent to polynomial
capacity with this very easy
transformation um and it's very easy to
see the connection here but i will also
mention this other this other work of
nishith which is different than this one
which kind of gives a little more uh
kind of detail about
somehow the the entropy interpretations
of this of this optimization problem
here this capacity problem
um
and uh yeah so this is also related to
like the beth approximation if you know
what that is um and so there's a lot
more connections here there's a lot of
deeper connections okay
okay
so this discrete case has been has been
solved before by previous works it has
this connection to capacity okay why do
i bring up this capacity okay so we saw
that this discrete maximum entropy is is
sort of
in very strong relation to polynomial
capacity and if you if you know me or
you know the things i like to think
about i like to think about this
polynomial capacity quite a bit so i
wanted to give you this aside of all the
different places that it appears and so
you know discrete maximum entropy
programs or some generalization also
appear
okay so here's the more general
definition right this is what i said
before you have this in femum
you have some polynomial here divided by
some some just product of monomials like
this okay this original definition is
due to girvitz
and it it has all sorts of applications
okay so the original use of this um and
implicitly the original use of these of
these discrete maximum entry programs
well okay not the original use but at
least through this capacity
is connections to the permanent to
compute to approximating the mixed
discriminant the mixed volume
some other combinatorial quantities like
integer points of polytope volumes of
polytopes okay there's quite a bit of
work on that there's also quite a bit of
work related to
doing optimization and some kind of
counting on metroid so if you want to
count the number of bases of a metroid
or you want to count the intersection of
two metroids um and also like i
mentioned before um this very recent
work that improved this approximation
factor for metric tsp in general
um
made use of capacity and capacity was
crucial to the to the um
to the analysis there
okay but then beyond kind of connections
to polynomials there have also been a
number of generalizations of capacity
which we've again we saw yesterday and
and we'll see throughout this week um
there are these
this capacity problem it turns out can
be generalized to some kind of norm
minimization problem over certain orbits
okay and this is very related to these
matrix operator and tensor scaling uh
problems there there's a lot of work
done there and i i there is
there's no doubt that i've forgotten
some work here so you know if i've if
i've snubbed you please you know say
something at the end so i can or even
now so i can make sure to include you
there um these orbit intersection
problems so you want to know when two
orbits intersect or or null cone
problems um and also this kind of
framework of non-commutative
optimization is very related to a
certain generalization of capacity and
also to statistical models um which will
which we'll see i think at the end of
the day today um at least one talk about
that okay
so so the point here is that right these
discrete max entropy problems that
there's a lot of connections a lot of
applications a lot of things known
there's even generalizations um that
that that can do a lot of things okay
okay but let's now get back to maximum
entry distributions
okay we saw in the discrete case we can
you know given certain things these are
efficiently computable there are many
applications even many generalizations
that are already known
okay
and so this whole talk so far has been
about whenever m has discrete support
and i can ask this question of what
about non-discrete support what you know
if you generalize to to some kind of
manifold what do you get and you and
maybe the first thing you're going to
say to me is well okay we already saw in
the previous slide there are a number of
generalizations too to think to be on
this kind of discrete case there are
these generalizations to do uh you know
norm minimization orbits maybe orbit
intersection like what are you talking
about what do you mean generalizations
to non-discrete support
okay
but but the point is actually those
generalizations from before are not are
kind of different than the one we're
going to consider here in this talk
which is specifically generalizing this
idea
this connection to maximum entropy
distributions um and i'll i'll say this
at the end but it's sort of a kind of a
conceptual open problem whether or not
the generalization i'm going to talk
about today is so how connected it is to
these other generalizations that that
deal with invariant theory and and
statistical models and all of this
okay so let's get back to this problem
that we started with okay
and now we're going to consider
um
m to be some manifold embedded in rn so
at first it was some set we restricted
to some discrete set of points and now
it's going to be some mana okay k is
still going to be the convex hole this
makes sense because you know this is
embedded in some rd so convex all makes
sense here
and we're going to again pick some point
a in the convex hole okay
and we want to find some natural
distribution on m which has a as its
expectation so let's just sort of
naively write down
the thing that we had before except
right instead of some sum we'll just
have some integral okay so i'm just
going to write this down very naively
okay
this sort of looks like entropy somehow
i'm still taking supremum over things
with the right support and the right
expectation maybe this will just sort of
work
okay but
actually there are some problems that
arise immediately when we try to write
this down
okay probably the most crucial problem
is this first one
that basically says
i mean okay i've written this integral
with respect to x
but somehow i'm kind of assuming right i
mean okay if this manifold was open some
open set in r in r to the d then this
would make sense we would have a vague
measure we could put it on this open set
we could take this integral and maybe we
could get something out of this the
problem is if we want to look at
something more interesting not just open
sets in rd it's not exactly clear
how we should integrate it's not exactly
clear what this measure should be okay
and and what this sort of means for us
is that
somehow this is the natural thing to
write down for entropy but because
there's so no sort of way to write this
um or at least it's not clear what this
should be there's no canonical notion of
entropy somehow the notion of entropy is
going to depend on the manifold m
uh through some choice of measure which
we'll see in a minute here okay
the other thing is even if this works
let's suppose like i could just write
this down and put dx here and everything
was fine
all of a sudden now this is a supremum
over some function space right in fact
it's infinite dimensional so i mean you
know before maybe this the space m was
very large um and we would have problems
doing things efficiently but here it's
not even clear you know if we can do
this optimization because of this this
infinite dimensionality okay so that's
something we'll have to think about
and also this is somehow similar to the
previous case in terms of um right i
mean if m is very large there's no way
we could efficiently write down all of
its entries right sorry all of it all
the points in it
but now it's not even clear how we could
even express m in a concrete way right i
mean m is some manifold we have to give
it some kind of description um we can't
sort of enumerate its elements um and so
these two are kind of linked they're
sort of issues with what happens when
you try to go to uh manifolds or more
continuous spaces but this first one is
the thing that we kind of really need to
handle before we can even we can even
move on okay so let's uh let's see what
we can do about it
okay so here's now we're going to do a
we're going to add something here i've
given a different picture to maybe give
you a very simple case where you might
or you might think about these types of
measures so okay like before we have m
is a manifold embedded in our d okay we
have this k being the convex hole here m
is just the circle the convex hole is
the disk okay and a at some point in the
convex hole and now mu
which i it's not really you can't really
picture it right but mu is now going to
be some probability measure on m
and just for the sake of this part you
can just think of mu as being the
uniform distribution on this circle so
we have some some natural way to talk
about the uniform distribution on this
on this circle and so let's just think
of it as that for now
okay
and once you have this mu you now can
write down
what i tried to write down before this
primal problem okay which is just
basically exactly what i wrote except
now there's this d mu okay so i mu is
some measure i'm now integrating over
this manifold and now i have this
entropy quantity
okay and this is exactly what we would
hope for
um or what we would think it should be
now what's
the thing that's that's less clear
but uh you know if you kind of work
through the details you'll see this it
turns out that this basically the same
dual convex dual uh
you can get the same expression okay
with basically the difference you'd
expect here instead of some sum you have
this integral with respect to this
measure
okay
so we have this primal problem we want
to solve still infinite dimensional this
is an issue we have this dual problem
now which is now finite dimensional okay
so this is sort of it reduces the
dimension in the same way that the the
discrete case did okay and by strong
duality in fact the the solutions to
these two are the same and so now we
have this infinite dimensional problem
okay but it turns out we can solve this
finite dimensional one and that's good
enough and as soon as we get this
solution y it also tells us exactly what
the maximum entropy distribution is
and so this generalizes this fact that
we saw in the discrete case these
maximum entropy distributions even now
in this more general case
of manifolds with measures on manifolds
are always given
by this log linear density with respect
to the measure we started with
okay
okay so we now have like maybe a problem
that we we can try to solve we have this
five dimensional optimization problem
that's gonna that's gonna give rise to
this uh
this this this measure that we care that
we wanna try to compute but now these
questions kind of now populate so the
first one is do why do we care about
this i mean like okay we can do this
what's what's the point
but supposing even we do care you know
for some reason which i'll talk about
how do we actually compute this okay we
still have this integral kind of going
on right before we needed some way to
compute sums now we need to be able to
compute these integrals okay which seems
harder it's not even clear if we can do
this and also what about the question of
sampling
um
can if suppose we can compute this can
we sample
okay
jonathan i have a question yep yes yes
somehow i'm just a little confused with
the formulas like the dual i always
think of it as like
it is being the dual to a relative
entropy problem
but
the primal i mean it looks doesn't just
doesn't quite look like relative entropy
can you clarify like what's the
difference between
this primal where where you're taking
with respect to mu and relative
yeah so so this this primal is actually
relative entropy
uh i'm like cheating a little bit here
this this new is really like the this
rad on nicodemus derivative
with respect to mu so this this really
is like minus callback leveler
divergence
i just wanted to write it in this way to
make it look like entropy somehow um to
give like the intuitions but but yes i
mean this new is
is really this it's like this density
function with respect to mu and so this
ends up being the kl there
that makes sense thanks
okay
okay
so let's look at a couple examples that
might motivate us to think about this
okay so the first one is going to be i'm
going to refer to as quantum entropy
okay and so there's there's already a
notion of quantum entropy out there this
von neumann entropy is often used okay
and
if if you're given some psd matrix with
trace equals one and lambda i are the
eigenvalues of this matrix then this
entropy can can be computed
in this way right there's a really nice
formula for it but but you can think
about this sort of as the the shannon
entropy of
kind of
a probability distribution associated to
the eigenvalues and in fact you can
think of
this as giving rise to some discrete
distribution
on the eigenvector pure states
associated to a so the rank 1 bsd
projections associated to the
eigenvectors of a with probabilities
given by lambda i okay so this is some
very famous quantity that's used in
quantum physics quite a bit
okay but there are certain issues with
this um there's actually
quite a few sort of more
philosophical works which is sort of
maybe an interesting
uh thing to say but there are these sort
of a lot of works where people kind of
criticize the use of this in various
contexts okay and often the critique at
least mathematically boils down to some
fact that
you can kind of think of this as some
minimum entropy distribution and or at
least the way you might think about this
is this is a very terse description of a
somehow the support
of this distribution that you're
associating to a is as small as possible
there's even some there's even a paper
that i read pretty recently kind of from
the early 90s where
basically someone is able to show that
if you use that if you if you look at
certain like i i'm a little bit rough on
this but it was some kind of non-linear
generalization of
like quantum physics
um and you looked at certain um
basically if you if you tried to compute
von neumann entropy there and and use
these things like for instance the
second law of thermodynamics which says
that a system only the entropy only
increases for the neumann entropy this
actually fails in these generalizations
i i unfortunately don't much know much
more than that but often these critiques
are related to this you have certain
generalizations of um
like uh
the rules of quantum physics you try to
apply
you know things related to von neumann
entropy and there are these issues where
certain things you expect to happen
break down
and often the the generalization that's
suggested is to instead of looking at
discrete distributions on on
eigenvectors to try to look at certain
distributions on all pure states so not
just restricting to these eigenvector
pure states but you want to look at some
continuous distribution on all pure
states and so
what this then kind of turns into
and there's this i'll just put it here
there's this work of slater in the early
90s who explicitly kind of writes this
down and
computes
for some small cases
basically what you do is you um look at
all distributions on the set of pure
states and you take the supremum over
the entropy quantity and you call that
the entropy of a
and so this of course is just this
primal problem from before
and now what what's our manifold what's
our measure well okay here this p1 is
going to be the set of all rank 1 psd
projections
if you think about what the convex hole
of this space is that's going to be all
density matrices so psd things with
trace equal to one
and now this there's a very natural
measure on this on this space
which is a har measure and this just
comes from the fact that
this set
you can act on by conjugation action by
the unitary group and i'll talk about
this more concretely a little bit later
but the point is you have some unitary
group action that gives rise as some
very natural measure and you can write
down this expression okay
and like i said the efficient
computability of this quantity was shown
uh by slater for some low dimensional
cases and the general case follows from
our work with this caveat that uh the
kind of the the complexity depends on
the smallest eigenvalue of a so if
you're you're very close to the boundary
the entropy goes to infinity and in that
case uh you start to think start to get
a little bit less efficient
okay
so that's that's one place where these
distributions appear another place where
this type of type of thing comes up is
in a particular uh place in interior
point methods
okay so there's this thing that's called
the entropic barrier function that looks
something like this you have some convex
body k
often it's compact i but i don't think
it needs to be
uh and you look at the supremum of this
of this objective here
and that's going to be some function so
your your v is sort of the a
from from previous slides
and it turns out this is some
self-concordant barrier function for
this set k and has optimal
self-concordance parameter this was
proven by ubekineldon a few years ago
and it's very easy to see right the the
only difference is maybe there's some
minus signs and this soup should be an
inf but basically if you negate this you
end up getting the optimal value of the
max entropy dual program
okay so that's that's maybe even why you
would call this the entropic barrier
function okay and in this case now our
manifold is an open manifold it's just
this convex set k
and
our measure mu is just the bag measure
restricted to k
okay
and there's an open problem uh related
to this barrier function which says is
this efficiently computable for k given
as a membership oracle
um and and we don't we don't we don't
answer this question but basically we
can reduce this this question to being
able to compute these integrals and
we're going to see this we're going to
see this a little more i'm going to give
you something more general here in a
minute um but basically it reduces to be
able to compute these integrals and then
there are certain i mean
for certain uh choices of k there are
maybe certain uh uh
there are certain
um sorry what am i trying to say there
are certain uh algorithms for computing
such intervals uh there's also a caveat
about if v gets too close to the
boundary um that has to be thought about
as well there but for the most part um
this kind of our algorithm reduces this
to be able to compute these intervals
okay and beyond these two things there's
also some other connections which i'm
not going to be able to really talk
about that much
there's some connections to the
isotropic constant which this is sort of
a maybe a little more of a hazy
connection i i can't say anything too
concrete here it's just that certain
integrals like this appear in this work
of clarton um in the in the 2000s um
and and there seems to be some
connection it's a little bit i can't say
anything too formal there um there's
also some distributions on matrix spaces
uh which which are basically maximum
entropy distributions in particular
these bingham distributions i i think
are are i guess they're a little bit
different they're distributions on the
sphere that can be derived from these
max entropy distributions and they
appear in things uh related to like uh
distributions representing like magnetic
fields on the surface of the earth so so
these are used in like some uh some
interesting applications
and there's also this kind of
cool connection related to this uh
goman's williamson work on the max cut
problem where i mean so the way that
they they kind of approximate get
approximate solutions for this is they
do some kind of semi-definite program
they get some kind of some positive
definite matrix out of this and then
they do this
this thing where they try to round this
positive definite matrix to some to some
vector and basically that rounding that
they do at the end of the algorithm um
they do it probably they do it randomly
they draw from some distribution and it
turns out that the distribution they
draw from is a maximum entropy
distribution um so so these things are
kind of around either implicitly or
explicitly in a number of places
okay and so we talked about a few
examples here where these things come up
but the question the other questions
still remain what about computability
and and still i also haven't talked at
all about sampling
okay
okay so now let's get back let's get
back to this general general setting
right we have mr manifold we've got this
probability measure on m
k convex hole point in the convex hole
okay and the main result of this work
with the sheath is that you can use the
ellipsoid method um
basically to
to efficiently approximate the this
maximum entropy distribution by by
getting a solution to this dual program
okay and in order to do this you need a
few things uh to sort of to sort of uh
you know we need a few assumptions
so the first thing is this mu needs to
have some balanced property okay
formally what this means is that
the measure can't be too small anywhere
basically if you take some small ball
epsilon ball in the manifold and you and
you and you determine how much of the
measure mu is there it can't be doubly
exponential basically it can be singly
exponential but but sort of no worse
than that
um
i'm sorry it says
i'm sorry say it one more time
a small ball yeah you know where is the
ball no yeah yeah a a euclidean ball yes
are you cl like a euclidean the rd
euclidean ball that's correct so so i
mean most of this ball is going to be
not in the manifold so i'm sorry so let
me be a little more clear you take a
point in the support of the manifold you
look at a small euclidean ball around
that point of course
this manifold is going to be of you know
potentially high co dimension so i mean
you're just going to be sort of
you're getting like a small ball um
i mean
like here's your ball a slice of it is
somehow going to be you're going to be
where you're you know your manifold and
you just you just yeah compute the the
the amount of measure in that in that
small ball and it just can't be too
small but yeah i mean if you if you pick
some some random ball that's not kind of
touching the manifold of course the
measure is going to be zero there so you
need so yeah you have to kind of center
your ball at a point in the support of
the manifold
does that does that make sense
okay okay
okay but but what you want to think here
is you want to think that the measure is
uniform
or i say symmetric here because if you
have some kind of symmetry properties of
this manifold basically then you just
have to kind of show this at one point
because then the measure is symmetric
everywhere and as soon as you can see as
soon as you can show this at one point
that that's enough and often these
symmetry properties i mean sort of say
that the measure is uniform anyway so
like whenever you have some some action
on the on the manifold that preserves
this measure pretty much this balance
property comes automatically
okay
we need then also that a is not too near
the boundary the potential problems with
this is that the entropy can get quite
large and and um in a way that is sort
of
makes the dependence on a bad in that
case so so if you're not too near the
boundary um and also you need this this
strong integration oracle for mu which
basically just means you need to be able
to compute this integral you also need
to be able to compute uh the gradient um
but but in most cases
if you can compute this then you can
compute the gradient like in in most
cases i would say this is the case and
so it really boils down to being able to
compute this function here
okay
and so then the next question is okay
fine so we've basically boiled this down
to be able to find these nice measures
and being able to compute these
integrals
but these integrals look potentially
hard when are we able to actually
compute these intervals
okay
and that's when uh symmetry comes in
um so
the the what we're going to focus on is
we're going to focus on this case where
m is some orbit of the unitary group in
the space of hermitian matrices okay so
let's fix some real vector lambda
okay
and we're going to
look at this orbit which is just you
take the diagonal matrix with entries
lambda and you look at all unitary
conjugations of that matrix
okay now this is the same thing as just
saying the set of all hermitian matrices
with specified eigenvalues
okay
and what's nice about this situation is
we have a har measure on the unitary
group and it immediately gives us an
invariant measure on the orbit okay i'm
going to call it mu lambda and because
it's invariant under this action of of
of the unitary group like i mentioned
the previous slide this pretty much
automatically gives you the balance
property i mean there's you have to
still do some argument but it it sort of
it's basically at this level of
generality you can prove balancedness
in general
okay so then the thing that remains is
how do we compute these integrals
okay so let's look at a specific example
and see how things go in that case and
then maybe we can see how to generalize
beyond that uh you have a question
oh
is this uh just a photoshop generated by
the fermentations of uh
so uh well this is not a polytope but i
mean if you restrict to the diagonal uh
of all of these elements then you will
get a polytope which is exactly what you
said
uh well it won't be it won't be a
polytope
right i mean this is some i mean this is
some orbitope i mean
it it won't it won't be a polytope
because you're looking at the convex
hole of some orbit of the unitary group
but the eigenvalues
will be in that
bermuda region
that you just met it's a spectrohedron i
think that's what i'll be saying
oh okay oh i thought i thought he said
so these type of orbitals have a
spectrohedral
uh
description as well
okay
okay
so let's look at a specific case here
okay let's this is the case that was
exactly what we did in the quantum
entropy situation
let's let our vector our vector lambda
just be have one one and the rest zeros
okay and so if you look at all unitary
conjugations of a diagonal matrix with
this diagonal you're just going to get
all rank one
pse projections and then the convex hole
will be all density matrices
okay
and there's a sort of polytope
connection here that we're going to
exploit
um
i put this moment map here in quotes
because i'm not going to talk about what
this means or why i use this term but
there is some moment map on on this uh
on this orbit
um which gives a very nice polytope and
if if you don't care about this term
then just think about this very simple
map that i've written down here so
here's what we're going to do we have a
bunch of matrices
i'm going to get a map to rn by just
restricting to the diagonal so i have
this matrix i just pick out the diagonal
entries and make that a vector that's
going to be my map
okay
and in this case we get something very
interesting when we do this okay in fact
the image of this
acting on this orbit is just the
standard simplex okay and this is pretty
straightforward because
well
this orbit
is the set of all hermitian matrices
with these eigenvalues okay so what does
that say about the diagonal
well
since the trace of all these matrices is
1 certainly the diagonal entries have to
sum up to 1.
and since all of these matrices are
positive semi-definite
it means that all of diagonal entries
are non-negative
okay and so these these diagonal entries
will be non-negative and sum up to one
and this is precisely the definition of
the standard simplex
so that shows that
the image is contained in the simplex
and it's actually not too hard to see
that it has to equal the whole simplex
okay but what's even nicer than that
okay we have this nice equality what's
even nicer than that is it turns out
that if you take this measure coming
from the har measure and you look at the
push forward through this map
you get the um
the lebeg measure restricted to this to
this polytope
okay
and by the bay i mean sort of like the
co-dimension one labagnet
okay you get this lebeg measure
restriction to this polytope and more
generally what that means is now if i
want to compute integrals like this i
just have to be able to compute
integrals like this and it turns out
that these are i mean you can write this
down as some iterated integral you can
also do some kind of fourier analysis
techniques to compute these integrals
these are sort of easy to compute
whereas this it's not clear how you
would compute them
and this also says something
kind of more conceptual which basically
is something along the lines of right
if if computing this is sort of
equivalent to computing this then it
also sort of follows once you think
about it for a little bit that that
computing max entropy distributions in
this case is somehow related to
computing maximum entropy distributions
in this case of course the convex holes
don't exactly uh connect but but there's
maybe bijection was too strong here i
maybe i should i should not say
bijection but there is some very strong
link between the the distributions in
these two cases
okay
so in this case we could compute these
integrals that's what we wanted to do
here by computing some similar integral
on a simplex
so how do we generalize this to
to other uh choices of lambda
okay we saw this connection before right
there was some big connection that
connected measures computing integrals
max entropy distributions
okay so now if we want to do this for
other lambda
let's uh let's just kind of try to do
the same thing we did before right so we
we have this moment map pi
we apply it to this orbit and we in fact
get this this polytope that i i believe
avi was was was talking about which is
what you do is now you take your lambda
vector you look at all permutations of
it and you look at the and you take the
convex hole of that
and basically for kind of
generalizations of the arguments i used
in the previous slide
um
all the diagonals of of elements in this
orbit are going to be contained in this
polytope and in fact you can show that
they are equal
so okay so we have this situation where
we have the exact same thing as before
we have this orbit we look at this this
map it gives us some polytope maybe
everything is going to work out
um the problem here though is we don't
the same nice thing as before the the
push forward of this of this
har measure that comes from the unitary
group is actually not quite the big
measure but only a piecewise polynomial
density times the vague measure
which may be and this is this is a very
famous
thing called the dowstermod heckman
measure or the decimal heckman theorem
okay and maybe this seems okay i mean
piecewise polynomial how bad can it be
um the problem is i i don't i'm not
exactly sure how bad it can be because i
have a hard time even computing very
simple examples uh i i don't i don't it
seems like most of the formulas involved
with this are very difficult to get your
hands on
um and so
i mean like i don't i don't really know
what what to do about this um this seems
like a hard thing if someone knows how
to compute these things that'd be great
i'd love to talk to you but uh it seemed
very difficult
okay and in fact though there is a fix
that's possible one can sort of choose a
slightly different map here and go to a
different polytope and and do something
there i'm not going to talk anymore
about that in fact i would if you like
this idea of kind of mapping things from
from manifolds to polytopes i'd
recommend watching collins talk next
where he should you know be talking a
little more about this this other option
here
um but we didn't do this
um instead what we did is we kind of
avoided this whole polytope connection
all together and and we just in fact
found a
a formula for this integral okay
and basically where it comes from is
this thing called the hciz formula
okay and and this formula what it what
it gives you is some you have some
integral over the unitary group of some
log linear thing related to some
hermitian matrices a and b
and it gives you this really
nice formula for these integrals right
this is somehow just a determinant
and and some some products of
differences okay
and so when you take log of this you're
going to get some some just sum of kind
of factors
okay
and it you know maybe it's not
immediately clear why this would give
you
an expression for this integral but the
way you it's actually quite simple once
you kind of write it down but the way
maybe you can see it here is if you look
at this ubu star that's appearing
somehow this integral is going over all
conjugations of this matrix b
and so what can sort of happen is you
can kind of replace this b
with
you know some some maybe other variable
that you're taking an integral with
respect to and that's exactly kind of
how this x appears here
okay so this is sort of
a different integral but actually these
are these are equal for pretty
straightforward reasons
okay
and so okay so we've we've right we at
least found some place maybe where we
had we had the ability to compute these
integrals right that was even a question
at the beginning can can we compute
these integrals ever okay now we have
some some situations we have these
orbits of the unitary group
um
okay but why do we care right um so we
can do this we found something we can do
why should we care to write this down
and also more generally like okay we
have this maybe somewhat specific case
of unitary orbits can we do something a
little more general than that
okay
so right on the previous slides we saw
how we can compute these integrals for
these for these orbits uh using the the
theorem i stated from before this
implies an efficient algorithm for
computing max entropy distributions on
these orbits okay
and so now the question is where do
these appear
well the first case we looked at was
this case where we looked at the orbit
of
this matrix with one positive sorry one
eigenvalue one and the rest zero and
that we knew already that was equivalent
to quantum entropy okay so we saw that
before
generalizing this
instead of just looking at e1 if we look
at the sum of e1 through ek so
this means all the matrices with k
eigenvalues equal to 1 and the rest 0
okay this
problem then right the the manifold you
get out of this is the complex
grasmanian and so this whole process
then yields maximum entropy
distributions on on a grasmanian and if
you care about grasmanians maybe this is
just
in general kind of an interesting thing
that you can do you have these sort of
canonical measures on
on a very well studied manifold
but also these are utilized in certain
low-rank approximation algorithms
especially when you care about privacy
because i mean essentially
i mean maybe i'll let this is a part of
our our later work with colin so maybe
i'll let him talk about this
um
but somehow right if you want to pick
out the the
dimension k subspace corresponding to
the top k eigenvalues of some matrix and
you want to do it in a way that in a
random way that doesn't kind of give
away the matrix structure
um then maybe what you could do is look
at these these max entropy distributions
and sample from the one associated to
your the particular matrix you started
with um and like i said that's that's in
our future work and um i won't say any
more about that um
it turns out that these specific cases
uh sometimes these com complex
longivonne distributions are are
precisely uh distributions which come
from these orbits and these are studied
in statistics
and also these this this density on the
unitary group this these uh this
this uh thing that we are taking an
integral of in the previous slide
these these are things are called hci z
densities which i believe uh colin we'll
talk about a a little bit more as well
these are used all over the place
physics random matrix theory and
actually
generally speaking even beyond his talk
i would recommend talking to colin about
these things uh at least in my
interaction with him he seemed to have
quite a wealth of knowledge when it came
to this um so i'd recommend talking to
him or you know asking questions in his
talk
okay and the other question i wanted to
answer here was what about other
manifolds okay so we need some kind of
right what do we need we need some kind
of measure maybe via some symmetry on
the manifold we're looking at and we
need an integration oracle
okay and so
um
we can we talked a little bit about
polytopes that come from this entropic
barrier function that could maybe be one
option right with the with the bag
measure
but kind of the main
generalizations of this that that at
least i know about is in some other work
with nasheed so this is a different
paper than the one i keep referencing
where we're able to extend a lot of this
to
adjoint orbits of compact lead groups
okay so you you kind of have a horror
measure coming from the compact lead
group
it goes to the orbit this hcic formula
extends to that case um and i i wouldn't
say i don't know if there's any kind of
like really explicit applications of
this so i'm not going to talk too much
about it but it is really interesting
how a lot of the lee theory has to come
into play to sort of prove all the
different points of what's going on so i
think this is a pretty interesting paper
just because of its connections between
lead theory and some of this entropy
these max entropy distributions
okay
okay
so so let me conclude um so in this talk
what did we talk about so first i i kind
of gave an overview of discrete maximum
entropy distributions and a number of
the applications that were that came
from those so things to combinatorics
discrete approximation orbit problems
normal minimization
statistical models
and then i talked about continuous max
entropy distributions which had a number
of kind of different applications
applications in that are sort of of a
different quality
um this quantum entropy interior point
methods low rank approximation
okay and the specific examples we looked
at were these conjugation orbits of of
the unitary group
okay and the point was here especially
when it went to this continuous case was
right you have this integral you have to
compute that seems intractable at least
a priori but but the point is that the
symmetries of the manifold gave rise to
not only the measures but also ways to
compute these integrals which made this
the computability of these max entropy
distributions possible
and so there's this question then i kept
asking about sampling and i never
answered it and so all of this is just
to you know convince you to watch
colin's talk after this where he'll be
talking about sampling from these
distributions
and uh and also finally there's a couple
open problems most of them or these two
are somewhat conceptual um the first one
is something that i have thought about
uh somewhat it's something i i really
wish there was an answer to
so
in this discrete case there were a lot
of combinatorics applications you could
get certain bounds on things you could
approximate certain quantities um
and and in the continuous case we did
have this quantum entropy that you could
that you could approximate but are there
any combinatorial applications that come
from the continuous case this this i
think is some kind of
i i don't know i expect there to be some
kind of link strong link between these
two but nothing like this seems to
appear in the continuous case
and also there's this kind of conceptual
open question i asked near the beginning
of the talk
um there's this whole other
generalization of the discrete case to
uh invariant theory norm minimization
algorithms things like this and then we
have this generalization that it's very
much about entropy and maximizing
entropy and it is i've thought about
this also uh quite a bit i i don't see i
don't see a connection there there are
little wisps of connections but it's
unclear exactly how connected these two
generalizations are or if they're just
kind of completely different
okay and that's it and thanks for
listening
okay questions
yeah
okay can you hear me
uh yeah i think so yeah
maybe
it's better
so hi
um
so i had
several questions but uh
so let me
begin with the so the uh
a question which was what is the
because you say we can
accurately approximate so the
approximation you measure it how so with
the difference with the objective
function or yeah that's that's correct
yeah
okay
you can get within epsilon of the
objective in like log one over epsilon
okay okay okay
and uh so
the other question was uh if you want a
bit more general so
basically so as you say that you do
you're doing coolback liberal
divergence minimization under a
linear constraint
which uh
so the the dual uh is very nice but
so you have just one constraint but this
duality uh usually so it's it's
it's more general and you can add as
many linear constraint as you want
so okay my question is if you
so
could it make sense to
not only fix the mean but all or also
fix i don't know the variance or
or something like that
and
affects the mean but also can you say
again
yes so
does it make sense to fix
not only the mean
but also
uh the variance or the covariance matrix
or something like that and then you
maximize entropy
or something
yeah yeah so so um
i'm not sure i can say i can say one
thing where maybe what you're thinking
of is the case of
how the gaussian maximizes entropy when
you fix the mean and the variance
um and and that case sort of corresponds
to if instead of looking at vectors in
rn you look at
rank one vectors by sending
v and rn to v v star
then kind of the the
the variance constraint
in rn corresponds to a mean constraint
in in now this psd code that you're
looking at right now your convex holds
the psd code so
i don't know in general about adding a
variance constraint for instance
um
but
there are under under certain
circumstances there are ways to encode
the variance constraint as a linear
constraint by by making some
transformation like the one that i just
mentioned i do i don't know how far that
it generalizes
um but
but but i've really thought a lot about
this kind of linear constraint case and
and maybe not so much about anything
else except for these ways to transform
kind of between between cases so i'm not
sure honestly
any other questions from the audience
how about the online folks any anybody
online want to pipe up
um i have a question um
uh
you mentioned this this constraint that
uh this point is not too close to the
boundary
yeah um of the convex hole right
that's correct yeah um
so i know that like nasheed has some
other work um and damien that where
they somehow get around this issue in
the discrete case
uh is it sort of intrinsic in the
manifold case that that's like a problem
or do you think you'd get around it
somehow so okay
that's a great question um because
you're you're exactly right that in the
discrete case the nishita and damian
have this work that gets around
um i don't know if it's intrinsic so i
think maybe for certain manifolds it
might be intrinsic uh like i don't i
don't know but i will tell you the
reason why that the stuff that the
sheath and damien do can't apply to this
because basically what they what they
find out is
they show that like
even though the optimum keeps getting
like basically goes off to infinity
the the objective function sort of
doesn't get too much smaller after a
certain point and so even though you're
maybe really close to the boundary
um and you're and you're up you're
you're i mean the
the optimal input is getting you know
going off to infinity you can actually
go very very far away from the optimal
input and still get an approximation and
they measure this by looking at kind of
uh like they look at the convex hole and
look at the facets of the of the
polytope um
for cases like say this the sphere like
looking at continuous max entropy
distributions on the sphere
i kind of expect so first of all you
can't do this because as you're
not there is no like bound on kind of
on your objective function i mean as
you're going to the boundary you're
going to infinity there's really kind of
no way around this um and especially
because there's no like i don't know
geometry to kind of maybe help you in
the sphere case i would expect this to
to not
like this to be an intrinsic issue but
but i'll be honest with you i i'm not
i'm not really sure um
i i've only thought about the fact that
you can't use what they did to kind of
fix this problem but beyond that i
haven't been able to figure out like
what what could you do to try to fix it
it looks it looks intrinsic but but
maybe maybe not i don't know
thanks
okay um if there's no other questions
let's thank jonathan again
[Applause]
i guess we resume again at
11.